how much and when did the german  government know about the NSA  surveillance program Chancellor Angela  Merkel under cabinet claimed the first  they knew about the issue was through  recent leaks in the media but does the  electorate believe them so handsome hint  of deep down they must have known but  they can't admit it publicly stop I  don't believe her if she's involved  herself plus she gets information from  the intelligence agencies maybe not all  but some definitely knew did the german  government know about the program  fifteen percent of Germans say yes but  eighty percent don't believe it a  stinker as this not support it's  understandable if they keep quiet now  and figure out what's really going on  Christian could remember there's an  election soon that's probably the  decisive issue tried now a special  parliamentary committee is to shed light  on this still shadowy subject and reveal  just how much the government knew about  us surveillance activities  you